Hey, how's it going guys! My name is PEEEEEWWWWDIIIIIEEEEPIEEEE
Welcome back to Uncharted 4 part 3
I don't know why I'm yelling, I'm just really excited to keep playing this game.
We're escaping from AH prison!
Because we stole we lied to the guy
We could have just paid him
Bad move, bad people
I don't know how I ended up here
I don't know why this treasure is worth it so much
I mean, four hundred million dollars is a lot of money
But honestly, where is Nicholas cage in all this?
That's all I wanna know, oh god, oH GOD
I think I jumped a little soon on that one, ow.. that looked like it hurt
Can we edit that out?
(dying goose sound) Jump!
Oh god, oh god, oh god, oh god
what the fuck is this place dude?
oh shiieeeet, oh shiet, oh sHIT
This game is so epic, I can't keep up man
(moan) It's so cool.. I'm amazed by every-AHHHHHHHHHHH sorRY
de fuk do I do (chicken cluck x2 )
Am I supposed to just take it?
I suppse I can take bullets, I guess.. I guess I'm not human after all
EY EY boi dude
Did you see that roll I did that
This game makes me sweat
Uhh.. Plan B.. Uhm.. I don't fucking know, how about that- Oh this way!
I'll take the box route! It fly- It flows so nicely.. Fookin' love it
we got this, come on Sam!
Sam is my brother, go Sammy Soo!
I could probably do that on my own.
Uh, What a dick! Yeah after you. Oh shit, oh shit, oh shit, oh shit.
Oh fuck okay   Oh my god this is so intense! OOOOOHHHH BRRRAH!
Come on.. OH NO SHIT FUCK! It always happen.
Ooh, oh It's up to poods, to kick some ass.. OH SHIT, oh nevermind, nevermind
I quit, I quit, I fucking quit. HUE! HUE! I bet you didn't expect that, bitch! Let's clean this shit up!
I'm gonna sit on his face. Oh shit, okay I'm gonna help'ya buddy. WOOH!
To a point, that's fair enough. I'm helping you buddy, we're bros, we're broskies.. hueee
I know I keep saying it but I'm  so impressed by this game, and I'm so into it and I'm loving it and I'm so glad I'm playing this game
It's been a while since I've been so into a new title, I'm really happy
It's just really cool to have this as my job especially when the game is so fucking good
Fuck it, let's just go for it
Where are we going?
Thanks buddy <3
Holy shit, HO, holy shit, I'm fucking crazy!
ARGHHHHHH
Fuck it's so intense man!
OOOOOOH SHIT I JUMPED TOO SOON! Oh I did it! Oh my god.. Oh god hurry up, hurry up man! ooh
Sam man, we're not leaving you behind, oh god don't, uhm just using my special move called.. uh.. Don'tFuckUp... ohh fucks sake..
come on Sam! We can't loose Sam now.. (Nissan??)  noooo.. He got shot.. Come on Sam the other arm!
We were so close..
You don't know that..
Come on Nate
What do we do?
Okay edit that out haha, oh god we have to go
Fucking hell..
But we lost our brother, what is, what is all the money worth?
Oh shit, oh shit
What the fUCK OH MY GOD, duude.. head first man that gotta hurt as fuck.
mageplask as we call it in Sweden
Dude what a fucking intro man
...What a fucking intro.
Jesus Christ..
That was just the intro?! For real?!
That was just the intro man..
We got an epic journey ahead of us bros!
Our brother died.. and I don't trust Rafael, fuck that guy.
But we're gonna find the treasure..
God damn.. so fucking epic..
(scoff)
Have you bros played the other uncharted games?
I played the second one and the one on the Vita (laugh) uh.. yes there was one on the Vita. It was good but uh
This one is really something else, I gotta say
It's so nice to see a game like this on an next-gen console.
Because so far all of the next-gen games we've seen hasn't been all that impressive but..
This is some cool shit man..
This is some cool fucking shit, ofcorse Troy Baker, as voice actor.. I like him but Jesus christ he's everywhere
The man with a million voices. (u talkin'bout Joe Sugg Felix?)
And boy is he hot too.. sorry.. did I say that out loud?
Mr. Alcazar. Good to see you
Get me out of here
what do we do with him?
lets go!
the others are in position
On my way. Everything goes according to the plan, sir
Great
You piece of shit! You will never get out of here alive
silence
Open all the gates
Hurry up
Oh shit!
Keep up the front!
And let them pass ... alive!
Fuck you, Alcazar!
We are in position. Are you ready?
Yes. Find cover
Mr. Alcázar?
We are fine
Understood. Follow me
The trucks are on their way
Very well
And this Yankee?
The Yankee is with me. He stay alive
We have to get out of here!
I have you, Yankee!
We cover you
Up there!
Kill them!
Almost there...
The area is secured
We are fine
Stop them!
Do not let them escape!
Ready to go?
Well done!
Keep up Yankee! I do not want anything to happen!
The tower! Beware of the tower
The trucks are on their way
Do not stand still
They can not stop us!
Down!
(No thoroughfare)
Water
Stop here!
Give me a knife
Come on!